you're you're very lovely you look
gorgeous thank you you did wear an eye
patch as a child i did what about you i
wore an eye patch on both eyes no i
wasn't
just to be safe it was uh
oh my god i had something called
amblyopia which affects a lot of people
really i've heard would you like to take
a moment to educate people about
amblyopa sounds like a polka song
oh i thought we could do like a psa uh
i'm sorry i was like all geared up to do
my alyssa milano these two quarters but
it's a it's a what is that she holds
them and she's like these two quarters
will feed every it's horse flap um but
horse flap i don't i don't want to say
horse crap so i said horse flap
it doesn't have to be trending it was
just for me i understand yeah hashtag
horse flap of course what
thank you for that this looks like a psa
for third base
what is what constitutes third base
that's
this is italian third base
oh
the spicy base
not doing this [ __ ] on fallon
um okay then it expands
oh that you're not okay with yeah
uh yes i wore an eye patch because
amblyopia is where one eye is stronger
than the other so you have to patch the
strong eye and make it pay for the sins
of the week
uh it's like it's like uh and then you
put over the good one and the bad one
gets worked out you have to do it for
four hours a day and so i had an eye
patch and then i had a special one that
went over my glasses
i went to private school in private
school like no one makes fun of anyone
because it's because public school it's
like yeah you think fast nerd number
private school it's like we don't know
how rich your parents are so let's air
on the side of caution
we have weirder looking kids there so it
was fine you had gla was one kid wearing
like an old-timey diving helmet
my father owns exxon
and now i can't cross my eyes like i'm
incapable of doing it what do you mean
so like can you cross your eyes like
what like this
well you can't either so maybe you did
not
that's what mine does one of the eyes
like it's supposed to be both
what do i look at
i think i like that this is what you're
supposed to do this is where my my nose
is you know transparent and it freaks me
out right
ghost nose
sorry teach me ghost notes that could be
a reality show like did you see it did
you hear it no one saw the ghost nose
but we heard it ghost nose ghost vision
so you're supposed to do my nose and why
is he back what vendetta could a nose
have i'm still doing new material as a
jew i can tell you our noses can't have
vendettas
mine did okay so it goes like this and
you both go like that
oh but see isn't that one like doing
something weird
you have no uh
i don't know what
on the plus side you have a fail-safe
way to end the date
thanks for going out with me
he drags his hook i take my weird eye
is it i don't know i don't know what it
does just thanks for sizzler buffet
i'm so glad you had a groupon